atrás de lo que vamos es encontrar la
suma de los primeros n términos de una
sucesión aritmética y que mejor que
tomar y empezar con una sucesión
aritmética muy sencilla la más sencilla
que conocemos 123 etcétera etcétera está
n porque queremos la suma de los
primeros n términos es la cuestión
aritmética en la cual vamos de uno en
uno ya la suma de los primeros n
términos de una cuestión aritmética
geométrica se le conocen como serie y
bueno vamos a ver cómo podemos encontrar
esta fórmula así que fijémonos en este
primer ejemplo quiero la suma de 12 más
3 + charalá hasta n bueno la forma de
encontrar la solución es poner otra vez
la suma pero ahora al revés empezar por
n
después le voy a sumar n menos 1 después
le voy a sumar n menos 2 después le voy
a sumar etcétera hasta el último número
es decir 1 el número inicial y bueno la
idea que hay detrás de esto es que vamos
a sumar tanto esta parte como esta parte
para ver qué es lo que me queda es decir
s n mã s n
de los primeros en de términos más la
serie de los primeros en términos es 2s
en después vamos a ir sumando cada una
de estas dos cantidades uno más n pero
con una peculiaridad los voy a ir
agrupando de esta forma de una manera
vertical por lo tanto uno más cn me da
en 12 más
n menos uno es lo mismo que n 1 también
en al menos 11 es en 1 me queda en el -1
a ver ahora tengo tres más n 2 y también
me da n uno porque 3 - 2 es uno positivo
y así obtengo este resultado en uno y ya
están viendo más o menos por donde está
agarrando este patrón al final me va a
quedar n más 1 y esto me va a dar en 1
todas las sumas agrupadas de esta manera
me dan de resultado n 1 y lo único que
hice fue sumar dos veces esta serie y
esto para que porque ya casi acabamos de
das cuenta que tenemos en la veces n 1
porque porque aquí tenemos en números
por lo tanto si cada una de estas sumas
verticales medio n
entonces tengo n veces n 1 n veces n 1 y
esto escrito en matemáticas me queda n
por n 1 y bueno esto es dos veces la
serie de los primeros en el términos de
esta sucesión si yo divido este lado
entre dos y estelar entre dos me queda
la suma de los primeros en de términos
de esta sucesión que yo tengo aquí
arriba de la sucesión más fácil
aritmética que conocemos es igual a n
por n 1 y todo esto entre 2 y nos queda
perfecto porque si nosotros queremos
saber cuánto vale la suma de los
primeros 100 números pues simple
sencillamente tenemos que poner en lugar
de n 100 y calcularlo y está muy
sencillo todo esto ya podemos encontrar
la suma de los primeros n números los
números que nosotros queramos ahora bien
esto lo podemos generalizar siguiendo la
idea abstracta para cualquier suma de
sucesiones aritméticas y como bueno pues
esto es lo mismo que n por n 1 entre 2 y
esto lo estoy poniendo aquí porque
fíjate que está en el término final de
esta sucesión éste
es el término inicial de esta asociación
y ya con esto generalizó la idea de la
suma de los primeros n términos de
cualquier sucesión aritmética lo único
que hay que hacer o lo único que está
detrás es calcular el promedio entre el
término final y el término inicial ya
esto multiplicarlo por n es decir n que
multiplica a n más a uno entre 2 y a uno
más a entre 2 es el promedio entre estos
dos valores y está de lujo porque con el
promedio entre el término inicial y el
término final encontramos la expresión
para tener la suma de los primeros en
términos de cualquier sucesión
aritmética